make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into the third
issue of four and I'm absolutely loving
this right I'm loving this whole thing
with four this story is ridiculously
good it's nuts right it's a pretty solid
story so what this does is this
initially picks up with for god of
thunder and like a bloody hammer right
slay my first thought because we left
the final of the I'm sorry the previous
story we left that with like beta ray
bill preparing to go to a conflict
before so my first thought is like oh my
god for kill beta ray bill that was my
first thought but what this does is it
really kind of highlights the nature of
for and it's one of these things was
very easy to lose track right because
you see for usually fighting alongside
like the Avengers right Captain America
the Incredible Hulk and Hawkeye and
black widow and all these different
characters and it's very easy to forget
the Thor is a nearly immortal being
right he has to eat the apples of a dune
so he's not officially in world he can
die of old age you know it's just it's
the nature of the beast
but he's exceedingly long-lived and this
is one of the things that Donnie Cates
really points out right he talks about
this idea that there are so many
unwritten stories about Thor or so many
stories about Thor that we just don't
know about because they seemingly passed
in the blink of an eye that in the life
of a person who will live thousands and
thousands and thousands of years what
could happen over the course of three
days is in the blink of an eye to them
Donnie Cates reverences the war of
realms and talks about how Thor was in
the war of realms itself kind of the
center of the whole thing and had been
fighting for two years and in his mind
it all happened seemingly in the blink
of an eye because what's two years to a
person who's going to live for two
thousand years it's kind of interesting
you know with regard to this whole
perspective of how Thor sees everything
and it's really just kind of designed to
point to this idea that the battle of
Thor is about to face despite all these
different battles that he's fought and
how forgettable they were at the end of
the day this is one battle that he's
never going to forget and the reason why
is because at this moment he's facing
beta ray bill and Bill's traditional
armor and it's kind of a cool thing
right because as soon as this happens as
soon as this opens up beta ray bill
immediately launches an attack against
Thor and has swatted away and like the
blink of an eye and it's kind of crazy
because this is where we get really kind
of a full-on explanation of the total
power that Thor has and hasn't really
been answered up to this point we've
kind of had to make assumptions but this
is the full totality of Thor's power and
he says as much at the moment right now
he has all the power of a Herald of
Galactus right so presumably at the
higher echelon with the exception of the
Fallen one there aren't really any any
any heralds out there that I believe are
in the same capacity as the following
one because the follow one was powered
by dark energy there wasn't like the
power cosmic right so right now we could
argue that Thor's on par with silver
surfer if not a little bit higher with
regards to the level of power cosmic
that he has what really beefs him up and
what really really amplifies him is that
in addition to the power cosmic he also
has a strength as Thor all the abilities
that come with it and they're all
amplified by basically having the Thor
force right having Thor's equivalent of
the odinforce right so this is basically
an answer to the question what if Odin
became a Herald of Galactus this is
brought to bear when he faces beta ray
bill and beta ray bill is absolutely
decimated right I mean literally it's
just boom there's there's no real fight
here beta ray bill has no real chance in
this conflict and that's what's so wild
about this because then I would ask the
question how does this version of Thor
compare to ruin King Thor rune King Thor
is way beyond Herald of Galactus store
right like ruin King Thor was a
multiversal concept he was multiversal
powerful right in terms of all the
abilities that he had and the things
that he could do and so on and so forth
this version of Thor is nowhere near
that level of power but he's a universal
level threat now right lane he's
universally powerful that's what makes
him so so exceedingly capable and why
he's able to overcome beta ray bill so
fast and this is one of the funny things
that goes on is that what he basically
says is that I chose this power right
like this path that I'm on I chose all
this and it's kind of funny because as
soon as that happens like Galactus
immediately makes his move goes to hit
Thor and the response of Thor is I I
took your power I accepted your power
but I can walk away from your power at
any point in time I do what I do because
I choose to and this kind of makes sense
right when it comes to the various
heralds of Galactus it's always been
that way
it's one of the things that sort of went
on the Galactus always allows or always
allows a free will to be maintained
among his heralds if the reason why
Silver Surfer was able to leave is the
reason why you ended up having the
Fallen one who tried to rebel against
Galactus and was locked away in the kiln
it's why you see these kinds of things
right why these these various
individuals who are bonded with the
power cosmic
go on to do their own thing and that's
kind of what's going on with Thor here
now we can also sort of surmise that a
lot of this is the Thor force right the
ability to kind of overcome that kind of
power now the reality is is even with
the Thor force
Thor is not on the same level as
Galactus right we even saw that during I
think it was Karen Gillan's run
of a four maybe it was it was Rick
Remender I remember who it was that
wrote it but were you had colitis yeah
you had Galactus facing off against Odin
you kind of had this telepathic battle
that went back and forth between the two
of them and then Odin just like
head-butted Galactus and and basically
fell into the odinsleep after that
because it required so much energy just
to like headbutt Galactus and crack his
helmet and so on and so forth not even
enough to overcome him and overpower him
and so it's kind of cool right it's
interesting to see that whole thing go
down because what this means is that
Thor even with the power that he has is
still universally powerful but is able
to also maintain his free will and keep
himself from being completely and
totally controlled by Galactus but when
he makes this statement of I chose this
path that's when beta ray bill gets
pissed because up to this point beta ray
bill was kind of under the mindset that
Thor was taken by Galactus and made into
his Herald and if that was the case then
Thor's will was not his own so beta ray
bill wasn't really fighting out of
disgust for Thor he was fighting out of
love for Thor right like I want to save
you from yourself
your will is not your own I'm going to
free you from Galactus as control and
then he you and I will team up and
probably fight Galactus and you know
make him run off or something along
those lines but hearing for say he chose
this right he chose to become The Herald
of Galactus lead Galactus to these five
worlds and then consume all the life on
them beta ray bill freaks out and
immediately starts attacking fork and
that's when he starts asking these these
really really interesting and really
important questions or Thor responds and
basically says like did you think it was
easy for me right did you really believe
it was easy for me to just make this
decision and just go off and become a
Herald of Galactus knowing that I was
leading him the world that we're going
to be consumed because at that point
it's not a matter of whether they're
populated it's five very particular
world those worlds have to be consumed
by Galactus it doesn't matter whether or
not they have life on them but his
argument is there's a more important
thing here this is really just a classic
argument of utilitarianism the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
for the people who were on those five
worlds those billions of people in total
sorry about your luck but the survival
of the universe is more important than
you and so you're gonna have to die in
order for the universe to live get out
while you can but that's basically the
way the game gets played it's just the
natural order of things would that being
the case I would kind of look at beta
ray bill and say like he's basically
wrong here he says like you could have
come to me you could have mustered the
entire armies of Asgard because you're
their king now but what are the armies
of Asgard in the face of a force
powerful enough to wipe out entire
universes right to bring about an end to
the universe before this one
what could the Asgardian army possibly
do the Asgardians were basically almost
completely and totally wiped out and
destroyed by the forces of Loki man gog
and like a whole bunch of other Dark
Elves and various enemies and stuff
during Ragnarok right and they're not
even nearly close to being Universal
level at the end of the day it really
just kind of looks like beta ray village
is kind of making excuses you could have
done this and you could have done that
it's like yeah but none of that power
would have worked you know it's one of
these funny things because it's
basically like Thor kind of keeping this
whole thing going and basically says I
do what I do because I'm King because my
job is to protect people my job is to
basically ensure that my people survive
and if that means becoming a Herald of
Galactus and then taking him to five
worlds across the universe and consuming
them destroying them so that my people
and the universe will continue to
survive that's exactly what I will do
that's the smart decision to make right
it's the right thing to do and it's kind
of crazy because at that moment he
throws his hammer at beta ray bill and
beta ray bill catches it now this is not
new right is that this is the the
hallmark and this is why beta ray bill
is so popular among the Thor fan base
and people in Marvel Comics who know who
he is right he was the first person to
lift the hammer of Thor so it's not one
of these things where Donny case is just
kind of like throwing it out there if it
was gonna be some sort of oh my god you
will believe what happened you know it'd
be a full-page splash right but it's
just a singular panel but Thor in turn
says let it go yet like nothing in the
universe can stop my hammer once I
recall it to my hand and I will rip your
arm off if I have to I'm getting my
hammer back the reality of this is it's
kind of looking at Fort right it's easy
to look at him and see him as a villain
but that's not true
right like Thor's fighting to save his
people and the universe's population
beta ray bills in the wrong here that's
really what it is and so as he continues
you know sort of pulling is pulling his
hammer back beta ray bill won't let it
go and so if Thor's response is okay
fine then I'll use a different one he
summons Stormbreaker breathes it to
himself and then shatters Stormbreaker
over the hammer of Mjolnir and then when
that happens beta ray bill basically
loses the hammer momentarily Thor
recalls it to himself and beta ray bill
is now weaponless beta ray bill has no
real weapon to use to overpower Thor
right Stormbreaker was his only real
trump card right it's like for not
having Mjolnir at the end of the day if
Thor is without his hammer
he's just a really strong guy that's
really all it is right it's only when he
has his hammer that he becomes virtually
unstoppable that's the kind of
capability that you're talking about
here
so that's kind of beta ray bills
equivalent when it comes to Stormbreaker
and so in response to this Thor looks at
beta ray bill as a person who will
always be in his way and that's true
because when it comes to beta ray bill
he's very much like Thor when he sets
his mind on the path of committing an
act nothing will stop him he will keep
coming and coming and coming and coming
he'll keep coming after Thor over and
over and over and over again until
either he's victorious or he dies and so
that's what for realizes is that beta
ray bill is never going to stop that if
Thor lets beta ray bill live Vader a
bill will leave and he'll come back with
an army and if that armies defeated
he'll come back with an even bigger army
and you'll just keep going over and over
and over again and then suddenly it'll
be the universe against for if you can't
even muster enough people to his cause
which I doubt he could right you know
hey guys
fors wanted to wipe out five worlds well
why do you want to do that bill because
if he doesn't then like the universe is
gonna be destroyed
okay well I'll really see a problem man
I mean it sucks it like those five
worlds are gonna be destroyed but like
the population of the universe versus
like a few billion people why is this
even a discussion right is it's one of
these funny things and so in the midst
of all that suddenly the Rainbow Bridge
opens up and out of nowhere comes SIF
the sister of Balder who took Boulder's
place as the person who oversees
everything and wielding his sword which
is no small thing basically says the
only way is through if you want to kill
beta ray bill you have to kill me
essentially Thor's being told you have
to kill a woman you were in love with if
you want to be able to continue your
mission it's pretty baller without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain to make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace okay I want to give
a shout out to Kyle B David Joseph then
John H AJ Matt and Jeff are John H lean
and mean which is an awesome name Jason
see Austin s Austin a Joey M Steven Z
Austin B Adam K and Genesis 9:6 team you
remember guys you can send me messages
and I'll run off whatever your message
is at the end of the video so long as
there's nothing crazy but if you want to
put a message in there
send me an email Rob at Robert Jefferson
comm and if you're one of these people
who get shout outs
then I will tack it in there
and yeah they should watch you guys
you
[Music]